hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong for an episode
i'm super excited about not the least of
which is because i get to talk to my
co-host jacqueline coley jacqueline this
is going to be hotly anticipated not
only because the movie we're talking
about but because of the movie that
we're talking about it because we're
talking about it does that make sense uh
not at all
i saw guns and roses last night so so
i'm slowly recovering but i will say
this there's a new movie coming out in
the mcu yeah and that one has some
connective tissue to the movie we're
talking about today and that would be
iron man three yes shang chi comes out
on
september 3rd and there is a connection
to this film we're not going to give
away any spoilers for the new movie but
we are going to talk in depth about iron
man 3. a movie that was very polarizing
when it came out jaclyn and i'm pretty
sure it still is
yeah i think it i think it is but as
polarizing as it was it was definitely
one of those polarizing ones among fans
people were definitely deep in the mcu
at this point and like they had
expectations
and this was i think the first one where
like
legitimately they were upset when those
expectations weren't met i don't know
was this before after dark world this
came out in 2013
so yeah so for uh those two right
together yeah the sequencing of the mcu
that's probably why we have special
guests like who we have today i will say
this iron man 3 is currently 79
certified fresh in the tomato meter and
it's 78
fresh on the audience score so seems
like it's a pretty universally
well-liked movie
is it though that's why we have our very
special guest today he is a tech and
geek culture host content creator
covering the space for over 15 years you
can check out his channel on youtube
it's just brian tong is his name
youtube.com is the channel slash brian
tong and he is brian tong who we got to
meet for the very first time seeing
shanghai all together brian how are you
it is good to see you again now my
friend
yes my friend in person in the living
flesh
so we were all on the uh the somewhat
red carpet for shanghai at the premiere
because sometimes they make a mistake
and invite me to these things but you
sort of recognize jacqueline or
jacqueline came up to you how because i
was the last one to this party
okay i'll tell my side of the story
because i think it's probably more
interesting so you know we're walking
around but hey look the fun thing about
this shangqi red carpet was
i would say compared to most red carpets
they weren't as locked down as they were
like you you could really free flow
around the main strip and so guess what
we free-flowed along the main red carpet
and uh i'm just kind of walking around
also and someone pulls me and says hi
and look i've never met either you or
jacqueline you know mark or jaclyn ever
before and she says hi to me and she has
these sunglasses and she's talking to me
like oh hey what's up right and i you
know it's the thing you do where you
pause but
to my credit
i it hit and i'm like jacqueline
and it was really cool to kind of like
see you guys in person you know finally
get get the energy of what we're like in
real life and also figure out how tall
we are compared to
i am deceptively short in these videos
and i've you're not the only person that
said that like like somebody else was
like because they've only known me in
like the pandemic times like they saw me
that night they're like i forgot you're
like taller and i'm like yeah
it's a thing you might be deceptively sh
taller no shorter in videos i'm
deceptively taller in videos
it doesn't really matter like it's one
of those things too where it's like how
many people more people see me on the
video
than they do the exact height that you
think i am
that is true
that is you are you are i'm 5 10 5 10
and a half on a good day my nba height
would be six foot one but that's who we
are we got to meet and it was great
meeting you brian because we talked
about the last episode you were on
mortal kombat and it was so much fun to
revisit that but now we're talking about
iron man 3 and we're looking back on it
i can't believe it's
8 years later since that movie came out
so i asked you first brian simply put is
rotten tomatoes right or wrong with
their 79 tomato meter certified fresh
rating of iron man 3. i'm gonna say
yes
i'm going to lean into yes knowing that
it was a polarizing movie but
uh from the rotten tomatoes community
that you know the aggregate
i'm gonna i'm gonna lean yes i'm gonna
lean yes
i think tomatoes is wrong
oh
i meant they're right you're saying that
you did me yes rotten tomatoes is wrong
so look we're gonna have some confusion
here even with the mandarin but
yes rotten tomatoes to me
was actually although we were saying
rotten tomatoes is wrong i'm gonna say
that score given
was the proper score was right
okay
very nice
we have to disagree with something along
these you know so yeah oh i think we'll
find some disagreements talking about
this movie before we get into all of
that we have a lot of movie talk we have
a lot of behind the scenes
but first we go to jacqueline coley
who's going to give us a succinct
synopsis of iron man 3. really don't do
that because this movie has a lot but
okay this is iron man 3 this is the
third installment of tony stark played
by robert downey jr in the iron man suit
as we sort of open you know tony is
still being iron man still trying to
save the day but he's got a few big
questions mostly his girlfriend pepper
potts is trying to get him to figure out
exactly what he wants to do going
forward he's got a piece of shrapnel in
his heart that he needs to get rid of if
he's going to continue to live on as the
iron man and wondering if he can do that
also there's a new president out there
who's maybe not the biggest fan of this
whole superhero thing but
iron man gets called out pretty early on
in the beginning of this by this
nefarious terrorist organization called
the mandarin who have been doing
experiments on folks including one that
negatively affects his boy happy and
that sends our iron man tony stark into
a fury he is not happy about the fact
that happy is being injured yeah you
like that and so he goes on his revenge
war page he tracks down the mandarin
sneaks in with like old school uh
devices
and it turns out that the mandarin is
not the mandarin the mandarin is an
actor uh called trevor slattery played
by ben kingsley uh also it turns out
that somebody from tony's past back when
he was really the playboy part of pale
uh playboy billionaire philanthropist
genius that playboy part is when he met
uh kelly uh killian is a killian yep
killing aldrich killian aldridge okay
killian aldridge played by guy pierce
um wanted to do some
research technology along with rebecca
hall they were basically trying to
figure out a way to regenerate human
tissue turns out after tony fired him
and shut down his research he continued
to research it on his own and well you
know what happens when crazy evil people
research they the experiments go wrong
and so he wants to enlist tony's help to
try and fix this regeneron stuff that
he's done that's gone all kinds of
haywire and in the big grand finale
climax he actually submits pepper to the
very same treatment that has made
killian all kinds of crazy and messed up
turns out with pepper it worked
she now has like weird superhero powers
after we think for like two seconds she
died but she actually comes back saves
the day fights tony they are able to
destroy killian unfortunately rebecca
hall who's like the genius behind his
nefarious deeds he kills her and uh all
the people who are negatively affected
end up being saved tony takes the
shrapnel out of his heart
throws away his you know circular spear
thing i don't even know what you call it
like his heart core activator sort of
signifying that no matter what happens
he will always be iron man and that was
kind of like the last thing that happens
before we go into captain american civil
war but this sort of sets up the
beginning of tony
not being able to deal with the fact
that you know aliens and weird stuff is
probably going to come and invade this
guy and you did a great job jacqueline
and you also hit on something within
that synopsis that i love about this
movie and that i really don't like about
this movie sometimes kids there can even
be one scene or just one line
that really changes the complexion of
the film for you that was the case for
me with iron man 3 but again i'm not the
most important part of this show it's
our special guest brian tonks so brian i
want to get into just a little bit you
said rotten tomatoes is right here why
is rotten tomatoes right about iron man
3. okay so you so round tomatoes give it
a 79 right so 79
79 when i look at the scope of movies in
the mcu that have released
i'm gonna say it kind of sits in there
even with
the twist of trevor slattery being an
actor playing the mandarin that turned
off a lot of the comic book community
now if you if i asked my friends who did
not care about comics i remember this
this was a heated debate at the time
they thought it was funny they they
thought it was kind of a fun little
twist if you were someone who at the
time with
thanos looming
and the mandarin who has his own 10
rings which represent different elements
of power potentially being on the table
as well knowing the history and lore
of the mandarin knowing that even in
advertisements they were kind of
pitching this movie as kind of like the
you know bin laden type terrorist fear
and everyone's like oh the mandarin
looks sick
if you're expecting that you're going to
be completely let down
but if let's say we strip away
the comic book nerd expectations that i
had
i i still think it falls falls right in
that range um the action was fun i
really appreciated the fact that they
you know tony stark has been this
playboy cocky guy the entire first two
movies this third movie he is deeply
affected by the ptsd that happens from
new york so you see a man who's no
longer
the guy we used to know but you get a
lot more texture and character in here
and let's also be honest if robert
downey jr is not the lead of this movie
this movie is definitely going to score
a lot lot lower so that's why i think
i i'm i'm aligned with the
79 score from raw tomatoes yeah shane
black directing this one and jacqueline
your turn is rotten tomatoes right or
wrong with that 79 certified fresh
rating i'm i'm gonna lean
okay
i hate this i got her thinking i got her
thinking now it's right-ish like like in
truth like i think that it's a good
movie it has a ton of action and a lot
but it's got plot holes the size of
texas that i just really can't
reconcile my brain around
and that third act is a bit of a mess
and
i'm just not a big shane black um
action fan i'm a good i like shane black
when he's doing like kiss kiss bang bang
you know type stuff like i like that but
like i just don't know if i'm as in love
with his
action efforts as other people does that
make sense like i like him nice guys
shane black that that version of of how
he makes movies i'm a little bit more
about but predator things like this i
don't know about it so
it's right but i could see it go a
little lower but definitely not going
out of fresh territory like i think it's
weird that it's certified fresh and thor
the dark world is just barely fresh and
i think it should be more in that like
high 60s low 70s but that's a quibble
and so you know no i'm with you though
but my my i'm a little bit firmer in
that i think rotten tomatoes is wrong
here i think that that score is too high
for this movie just because you can look
at at iron man 3 if it was a stand-alone
movie and like brian said we didn't have
any expectations going into it as to who
the villain was going to be as to how
our hero was going to react then yeah
fine it's a it's a good movie but it
also is in the mcu and it's also iron
man 3 for a reason because we had a
bunch of mcu movies before we had a
bunch after it and i just do not feel
like iron man 3 the entire film holds up
to the standard that the mcu has set
particularly the standard that iron man
has set and so i think that iron man
3 and 2 are around the same for me but i
think that iron man 3 belongs in like
the low 60s i can give it fresh but i
think it belongs in the low 60s before
we get to two minutes with tim i do want
to bring in producee lucy real quick
producee lucy you got a chance to
revisit iron man 3 with your family the
family take at perducy lucy's household
is rotten tomatoes right or wrong rotten
tomatoes is wrong i
cause you there are things i like about
cause
because i don't like it oh i feel bad
i'm sorry so ultimately i tried i put it
on last night i saw in theaters when it
first came out which i can't believe
it's been that long yikes i kept
thinking about that all night long that
was right around the time that some guy
was ruining the chance of him ever
hosting a jeopardy
no
shot fired i tired
i tried to watch francis hold up francis
stop my kid's about to break the fridge
leave it open
sorry
one second baby it's okay so i tried to
like finish
that's literally the noise i make when i
was especially this is what happened the
shanxi after party we were just crying
and crying and crying last night no
um i tried to watch it um
i just kept finding myself being like
i'm gonna turn this off like yeah i'm
gonna turn this off this is boring this
is boring
i did keep watching it though
but overall i just it didn't
it didn't capture me the way iron man
one did
that that's gonna be hard to match
yeah it is it's a very high bar that
they set right out of the gate with the
very first iron man so that's that's why
we love producie lucy she has kids so i
don't have to now we go
to the celebrated segment that is what
the critics were saying at the time of
iron man 3's release way back in the
dark ages of 2013 our segment is two
minutes with tim ryan our expert review
curation manager rotten tomatoes tim
please
[Music]
let's break down the three iron man
movies by the numbers iron man is
certified fresh at 94 on the tomato
meter with a 91 audience score iron man
2 is certified fresh at 72 on the tomato
meter with a 71 audience score and iron
man 3 the subject of today's podcast is
certified fresh at 79 on the tomato
meter with 328 reviews and a 78 audience
score
and based on my own observations just
about everyone i've ever talked to says
iron man 3 is not as good as the first
one and better than the second one so it
seems safe to say that as a mini
franchise within the marvel cinematic
universe when it comes to both audiences
and critics the iron man movies are
properly rated but what did the critics
have to say about iron man 3 in a fresh
review bill goody kuntz of the arizona
republic wrote downey is as funny as
ever if not more so he ensures that iron
man 3 is a solid installment in the
franchise and helps to make it seem at
least for a time that it might be
something more
however in a rotten review a.a dowd of
the av club wrote it's hard not to wish
downey were sparring with his costume
comrades again instead of trading barbs
with the far less colorful cast members
old and new of this busy sporadically
diverting sequel
the rotten tomatoes critics consensus
reads with the help of its charismatic
lead some impressive action sequences
and even a few surprises iron man 3 is a
witty entertaining adventure and a
strong addition to the marvel canon so
that's iron man 3. and just remember you
can take away their houses all their
tricks and toys but one thing you can't
take away
they are
mark and jaclyn back to you folks
well thank you tim that means a lot um
i am defined by my toys and my tricks
however so let's get right into it i
cannot wait to talk about this movie
with you too let's get to movie talk of
iron man 3.
[Music]
let's kick off with that brian and
jacqueline the the rating that y'all
have as far as where iron man 3 works in
iron man cannon so we won't do the
greater mcu for right now i just want to
hear brian first your take on iron man
3. is it between iron man and iron man 2
like a lot of folks according to tim
says it is or does it hold a different
spot for you
100 agree with that i mean iron man 1 is
the peak
iron man 2 was like really guys i hope
you redeem yourselves in three and iron
man 3 was like oh you kind of did so i
think i think that's right on the money
you kind of did how about you jacqueline
man i don't even remember what we said
on the iron man episode like that's why
i'm like worried like the iron man
like i don't remember what we said look
there's a lot of movies we do a lot of
movies so like i would i'm like i think
is it one two three i don't know like
this is the deal with two and three in
my personal opinion
depending on the day
i might enjoy one more than the other
because like two i remember i had more
fun with it than i remember
but i can't like put it in context with
this one because both of them are sort
of like imperfect little misfit toys
that i will enjoy playing with now and
again so i would say today i will put
iron man to
yeah i guess i'll put it lower
i'll put iron man 2 lower but you could
definitely uh put me on a moment where i
would go reverse and let's be honest um
lower by like what it's like the olympic
medal stand it's like well you all met
up which is barely lower but
iron man 3 for me does get a bronze
medal because after revisiting iron man
2 for the show that we did i feel like
iron man 2 is just a better movie than
iron man 3. now the first half of iron
man 3 might be the best iron man movie
i've ever seen but yeah
you going back to jacqueline's olympics
reference you got to stick the landing
and i think that there's multiple facets
where this movie just completely falls
apart uh brian you said you agree with
rotten tomatoes that it's 79 so there's
got to be stuff in here that you really
liked what's the scene or a moment for
you that you point to and you say yeah
that's why iron man 3 is definitely a
fresh flick
well what surprised me is when i went to
watch this movie again for this podcast
it was better than i remember i actually
ranked it lower than two
um initially right i had or sorry i had
one two and three in that order of the
iron man films but after watching three
and it's not a recency bias i said okay
three levels up a little bit i thought
the action in two and whiplash was
better and the ending scene with him and
war machine and two was kind of just
like a nice clean way to like you know
have that finish up but here you know
you got a little bit a lot of like when
when they start throwing 30 iron man
suits you're kind of like oh here we go
again right like it's like
but
i did think the the ptsd and the
relationship with the with harley with
um with it what's the actor's name is
tai what's his last name i can't
remember but
that yeah yeah that ty simpkins thank
you that that there's heart there and
i'm i'm kind of like that character
development guy when it comes to
superhero movies i like to see that
stuff so uh that's why it's still kind
of bumped up for me yeah the the
relationship that tony develops with
this kid in the dead of winter in
tennessee i think is one of the
highlights of this movie jaclyn but you
i've heard this criticism a lot is that
iron man 3 is a great shane black movie
but it doesn't necessarily mean it's a
great mcu movie if that makes any sense
who's that
sorry
mark says
no that is people who have not seen the
nice guys or i have my bags i have my
ears to know people who like the nice
guys and who like kiss kiss bang bang
are like yeah this iron man 3 is great
for that but fitting into the mcu not as
much and this was right around the time
that there were starting to be rumblings
like well yeah i mean we all love marvel
but they just don't have as good of a
villain as dc comics movies and so we
saw the mandarin ads we're like oh this
is the guy this is the thing that is
going to sort of turn that on its ear
and it didn't really work out that way
but give it up for kingsley like i will
give it up for ben kingsley giving like
trevor
just absolutely hilarious they did like
um extended little features with him
talking about like like these little
like extra videos the the iron man 3
blu-ray has a lot of like extra stuff in
it i think that's shane black leaning
into his like i remember vhs commentary
days and so there's like a lot of stuff
like that extra where they were like
look i got ben kingsley and he basically
is a glorified cameo we're gonna have
fun with it right
um so i actually enjoyed that oh i don't
hate ben kingsley's performance for what
he was given at all i think if there's
anybody that could have pulled it off it
probably is sir ben kingsley but you do
have that twist that is getting into act
3 where we find out that this big bad
mandarin is actually just a hired actor
from more nefarious purposes from
somebody else and he's not a terrorist
at all he's just this out of work drunk
actor and ben kingsley does do
as great of a job with that and that's
not even the thing that bothers me the
most about this movie the thing in act 3
that really bugs me that really gets
this below iron man 2 for me is that
again i said it sometimes it's just a
scene sometimes it's just a moment
there's a moment where we think that
pepper potts dies where she falls and we
think that she's gone we think that she
literally died i got you relax i got you
just look at me
honey i can't reach any further and you
can't stay there right you got to let go
you got to let go i'll catch you i
promise
[Music]
and like half a second later tony stark
he's in a fight as iron man and he's
just back to making quips and one-liners
and i just do not buy that for that
character at all that he's gonna be just
doing his normal thing when he just
found out the on-again off-again love of
his life is falling dead on the platform
below him
did either one of y'all pick that up or
was that just like me being too
sensitive
mark did you really believe
that pepper potts was dead yes no i
didn't i didn't at all and that's why
all these emotions that you're telling
me yeah i didn't feel them all i'm like
she's still alive she got like she's got
the extra miss in her
that's the plot hole part that i'm
talking about like none of the emotional
none of the emotional motivations really
hold true like the idea that that iron
man is gonna go on some like john wick
revenge for happy is really weird too
like i get he's like sad about happy but
like people die all the time as
collateral damage around this dude and
like all of a sudden happy gets hurt and
it's like where is she like i'm it's
just weird you should be used to it by
now you know and so i i don't know to
your point you're right it doesn't fit
with the character in a certain respect
um but that's what's great about civil
war
um because when we get to civil war and
the like you killed my mom scene like
was like that that was a different
version of how that could have played
out
um that the russos did in that moment
does that make sense it it does but
brian i don't know about you when i saw
a captain america civil war i thought
tony should have been able to hold it
together more than he did no weep
dude it's his mom it's his he made his
million dollar video it was 25 years ago
aged and back no
that's yeah if you find that out about
your mom it doesn't matter if it was 25
years ago it doesn't matter it really
doesn't ugh my mom listens to every
episode of this too mom i love you i'm
sorry
do not be friends with anybody named
bucky who has a weird arm don't say the
words around him
i'll make your mom feel any better i'm
not sure i'd go on a revenge story
[Laughter]
for my mother not nothing nothing
against her as a person but there's just
not a lot maybe my dog if you came after
my dog i would go john wick but that is
literally the only creature on this
earth that i have that much pure love
for and he and he licks my face i'm i'm
with you right there i'm looking at
molly the wonder dog and i would murder
for her so people i'm like we we all
know what's good like we know how this
book is gonna end it just depends on
which chapter especially
in this universe and that is one of the
things that i really loved about the
first half of iron man 3 is that it is
setting up tony stark as the same like
you know fast talking guy that we love
from one and two but it also is moving
his character development forward with
the ptsd angle where he says you know
nothing's been the same since new york
and it's like him and and rhodey are at
hooters i think but but they're having
this like really like deep intimate
conversation about those events and i
really responded to that i thought that
was so well done and necessary because
you can have 25 fun comic book movies
but you don't really have a lot of
connective tissue or get to care about
the characters as much if we don't have
stuff like that and so i think that was
a very necessary thing
for iron man 3.
brian is is there one thing in this
movie that you said well yeah maybe that
is why it's not as good as the first
iron man
um
the well again critics depending on
where they leaned on how much they loved
marvel movies it had to be
trevor slattery's role in the movie
right i think that's going to tip
however you feel about that specific
plot point that's going to tip your
skill whether you choose this to be
rotten or fresh in my opinion with all
the plot holes with all the little
things that we may have liked a lot or
didn't like at all that's really the
tipping point of how you kind of
evaluate this movie and you know we're
not going to talk about any other
spoilers but i think when you look at
the entire mcu now
maybe
trevor slattery's role is looked at
differently today from iron man 3 than
it was
you know a few weeks ago like how did
you i think that that that context
changes it in when you're when you are
watching it in the theater for the very
first time and that that twist happens
like we said again we're being set up
the whole movie that the mandarin is
going to be maybe the biggest evil that
we've ever seen in the mcu tony stark
talks direct trash to him via the news
and gives him his home address and then
the whole thing gets blown up
did you like it at the time you're
sitting in the theater start with you
jacqueline did you like it at the time
and then were you walking out of the
theater and you're like wait wait wait
that's what we got or was it weeks later
was it years later
i actually think that i've never seen
this in the theater the first time i saw
this was like during an mcu re-watch
like gearing up for maybe
i think gearing up for civil war yeah it
wasn't gearing up for infinity but i
like wanted to make sure i'd seen
everything
leading up to civil war or maybe winter
soldier somewhere in there and so i
watched everything and that was actually
the first time i saw iron man 3.
again the 2013 i don't know what i was
doing but i just was not i was not as
into going to movie theaters at the
theater as i am now and the movies i was
seeing was not these type of movies i
think that was like deep in my like i'm
going to the library a lot yeah i just
it i hear 2013 and sometimes it feels
like jack and i've been doing this for a
hundred years because we just we know
how to do the thing by now and so i just
assumed that we saw every movie together
in theater yeah
yeah no um yeah i don't remember what i
was doing but i definitely didn't see
this one in the theater i i need to go
look and see what else was out like that
year because i know i saw
i know i saw civil war in the theater i
know i saw that in the theater but i did
not see iron man
so brian how about you you're you're in
the theater i assume watching iron man 3
and
the mandarin twist happens are you like
yeah this is perfect this is hilarious
or are you like what are we doing here i
i was i was like
that just spoiled the whole movie for me
when i saw it because it was it was also
really kooky i mean he's in the bed with
these two ladies
iron man pulls the sheet off and he's
like
don't move i'm not moving you want
something take it although the guns are
all fake because those wankers wouldn't
trust me with the real ones what hey do
you fancy either of the birds
heard enough
you're not him the mandarin the real guy
where
where's the mandarin where is he whoa
whoa whoa he's here he's here but he's
not here he's here but he's not here
what do you mean it's complicated hey
it's complicated nice it's complicated
and then you're like okay like you're
not really sure and all of a sudden you
realize this has been not only a ruse
but a really kind of campy one
and so it kind of almost takes you
out of the mcu because we had never seen
anything like this in the mcu before
along these this lines of like
flipping the script kind of
not only trickiness but really just kind
of not being rewarded for all this
anticipation that you've been waiting
for and then you layer on the comic book
geek fan that i am
that was like another gut so i remember
leaving the theater being like
um that was really crappy like i didn't
i looked past look
uh brian tong in 2013 didn't care about
character development as much as he
cared about a badass movie right and so
that that kind of that really
you know i was i this is a movie that
i think i've maybe only seen
one more time outside of the theater
before i watched it and that's kind of
when you when there's an mcu movie that
you've really only seen one more time
it's probably not going to be at the top
of your list and so it left a bad taste
in my mouth for a while um but then
watching it recently
i i felt better about it
yeah there's been certain developments
in the mcu
of late that i think make me feel a lot
better about that whole twist with the
mandarin with ben kingsley's character
but at the time i was like this
it felt cheap to me and it and it felt
like borderline insulting to me as an
audience member that again a lot of this
is marketing too because we've been
inundated for months and months with
trailers and promo materials saying look
out for the mandarin this is the
the scariest enemy we've ever seen here
he comes and then it just turns out to
be something else we did get a baddie in
the film and that would be guy pierce's
killian did either one of y'all respond
to killian as an mcu villain i just knew
that he was evil like guy pierce shows
up he's either weird or evil very good
looking though like i mean like it's
sort of like the dude that we saw from
the holiday the guy that played jasper
anytime that dude like shows up like
rufus sewell yeah rufus you are not
gonna be a good dude so i knew guy
pierce was like
yeah and the fact that he's doing his
best uh enigma
uh from the riddler yeah edward nigma
from batman and robin like fan girl turn
fight like they literally gave him the
same turn this is like batman forever
turn that they gave him like i love you
so much and then you know i'm going to
come back all cool you know that that
with this back hair with the slick back
hair and rebecca hall on my shoulder so
yeah i knew he was going to be evil also
i don't i that was spoiled before i saw
it so when i saw iron man 3 i knew
bing kingsley was so it was already
spoiled so i don't know how it would
have reacted but um i'm never going to
be sad to see ben kingsley
pop up in a movie uh brian favorite
least favorite characters from iron man
3. new ones ones we've established and
just didn't like the way the ark went
well i mean in the moment least favorite
character easily had to be trevor
slattery
in the moment
right um favorite character is gonna be
i mean it's gonna be tony stark i would
almost lean towards harley a little bit
as kind of my second favorite character
of the movie um the young boy the
dynamic with him it was awesome but
again like i said be at the very top of
this if if this is not a movie led by
robert downey jr i mean this is might be
a sub 60 movie quite honestly i mean but
this is i've seen i don't know man i
watched thor the dark world i'd watch
that over this throw the dark world yeah
go to the dark world watch it again you
get eric selvig walking around half
naked you get loki
you get loki like going through his emo
fantasy because his mom died like legit
there is some stuff in thor the dark
world i'm sorry i'm about it um
they do portals and you know
about it that's about it but whatever
the portals are cool
jaclyn you did you did hit on something
at the top that i wanted to bring up
during this section is that there's some
plot holes in this movie there's some
things that don't really make sense that
we don't really piece the puzzle
together all that well one of which is
being and i've seen this in a lot of
articles
that iron man is spending most of the
movie trying to repair slash like power
up his suit but then at the end
it appears he has a remote controlled
armada at his disposal that is nothing
but iron man suits how does how does
that work am i missing something
jacqueline or bryant or is that the
movie's fault that's the movie's fault i
don't know if this was i don't know if
this was the plot does anybody feel like
this movie got changed in like rewrites
or like totally totally yeah yeah from
the first after the second half like i
said the first half is one of my
favorite iron man movies but the second
half just feels weird
also like
the the i went back and watched the
trailer the trailers to your point just
set us up for this really dark third act
we knew that we were still going to get
robert downey jr i think at that point
but like it very much seemed like you
know not not all the casted characters
may make it out of this and and then it
ends up just being the same schmaltz
also um thanks shout out to mark
hofmeyer about this um i did not know
that they tried to shoehorn this as a
christmas movie did you all know about
this wait was a christmas movie yeah i
mean
there's christmas elements and like
shane black loves making christmas
era movies and so i i think that's like
the debate about it i i don't consider
it a christmas movie do y'all it could
be a holiday time holiday time movie
based on but definitely not christmas
apparently it's like
it's a wintertime movie i didn't know
that i did not know that i did not know
that but it came out in may that's
what's super weird
right is that i think marvel now says
that it's a christmas movie but it
literally was released like
what's the is that seven months before
christmas
it's many months they said it pretty
much the release date matter i think
it's more about like the elements but
still it's whatever i didn't mean to
like steal your thunder mark but i did
not know that until i was literally
reading this article
on
on the research and i was like what but
it does not iron man does blow people up
with a little homemade with ornaments
jingle bells yeah jingle bells yeah that
that's a that's a point that it could
that's christmas set if you're using an
actual holiday ornament when he was
infiltrating the miami facility remember
that he threw him they were like
explosive things yeah wow lucy
this this is the one that needs to go
further than die hard like this
you can make a legitimate understanding
he says ho ho ho shoe horning christmas
into this
but after he saves gwen gwyneth paltrow
he's literally like
it's christmas that doesn't count that
is stupid that is stupid lethal weapon
has christmas elements like legitimately
christmas elements are in lethal weapon
and i know that shane
is more of a christmas movie than iron
man 3 in your opinion we all agree die
hard is christmas movie that's that's
that's really perfect
and also i put lethal weapon more in the
non-action shame black because although
lethal weapon has action in it is much
more about like crazy riggs and raj than
it is about
like this one with like huge huge
explosions and all of that kind of stuff
you know what i mean
i think lucy's kind of changing my mind
though because she mentioned ornaments
they say christmas and it snows
and there's holiday decorations at the
bar
so
the white house has their christmas tree
out
there's you know he buys pepper that
giant dog maybe i'm wrong because he
seems so weird
that's right this seems so weird
all right well if you all want more
weirdness then if we're talking about
with the weapon and die hardest
christmas movies with the weapon
released in march and die hard released
in july so yes you can have a christmas
movie released out of season i just
don't know that iron man 3 counts as
much of a christmas time movie but i
will give brian props for saying that
meeting us in the middle and just saying
it's a it's a winter-based movie yeah
it's holiday-ish
it's it's a movie with christmas
decorations
okay
ladies and gentlemen that's great
i will never top that moment right there
for this rest of the podcast christmas
decorations that do apparently blow up
and so uh last last list before we move
on to behind the scenes about any
character any any part of the movie that
you felt strongly about one way or
another brian start with you anything
else that you needed to get off your
chest here um i just think that even
though you could argue
what this movie accomplishes from
beginning to end
isn't that much it's all about tony's
character building towards civil war
without acknowledging there was no other
movie that acknowledged the aftermath of
new york like you it would feel so
inauthentic for the next movie to be
just another blockbuster where no one
feels any of the ramifications of what
happened in new york and the chitauri
attack so
from that respect when you look at the
entire scope of mcu this is actually
pretty crucial and like we talked about
it kind of set up his mind
of where he's at from a character
standpoint into civil war
so you know on the surface you may not
think it's that important but that that
is pretty crucial to the arc of tony's
character that's a great point
jacqueline that's a tough act to follow
sorry yeah i'm just gonna cop out and
say i really love that they gave us a
new heart styled sort of you know a
dallas when um they open the open the
curtain at the end with the post credit
scene for this one where bruce is like
falling asleep as tony tells the story
so what were you with me it was yeah
we were at uh are you actively napping i
i was i i i drifted where did i lose you
elevator in switzerland
so you heard none of it that's like
probably the first of what i would call
the marvel cop out cut scenes because at
this point they'd already trained us to
sit down and avengers we got shmarma
which is like shawarma which is like not
really what we're expecting at that
point by the time we get to iron man 3
they're like you're just lucky we're
putting something at the end of this
we're not necessarily going to give you
any new characters don't be thinking
that you know sam jackson's going to
come out talking about the avengers
initiative y'all just be happy that
we're here so i actually appreciate that
moment um and just the bored look on
mark ruffalo's face which to me is why
mark ruffalo is kind of a perfect hulk
like he can do
he can do both if you feel that is so
funny so iron man 3's post-credits scene
walked so that spider-man homecoming's
post-credit scene with captain america
could run yes that egg
is the perfect way to end movie talk and
post-credit scene talk and now we'll
move on to behind the scenes
[Music]
this movie fun fact is with the avengers
flicks and black panther as the mcu
films that have done over a billion
dollars of business at the worldwide box
office and so iron man by this time was
obviously an established beloved
property the fact that this movie made
as much money as it did i don't think
really pretends to the quality of it in
reference to iron man two or one just
because by that point we were all iron
man crazy and we felt like iron man was
the closest connective tissue and gave
us the best opportunity to see more mcu
characters popping in which as
jacqueline said we got in the
post-credits scene we got to hang out
with rody for this movie a little bit um
what's funny is that anthony mackie
auditioned for both iron man and iron
man 3 and sort of caught the eye of the
russo brothers and
who were making who were working on
captain america the winter soldier at
the time i guess and so that's sort of
his intro into the mcu and and i guess
my question for you all is when you
think of the mcu and you think of how
all the money that it's made it's weird
that iron man 3 is in the billion dollar
club because it's not a movie that i
associate with being like one of the
tentpoles of the mcu you know i think
that you also have to place it in time
where
we do we did start seeing superhero
movies but even though iron man 3 wasn't
the biggest contributor to you know
changing things up at this point the
momentum for mcu
is pretty high i mean there aren't that
many superhero movies even in theaters
right people are getting comfortable
with the idea
of superhero movies now being kind of
like the flagship events to go to and
it's the third one and we know how
especially with the iron man brand and
the mcu kind of really everyone's going
oh now this is the point where i'm
telling some of my non-comic book
friends it's time to start paying
attention to this stuff right
that's i think why we see those huge
numbers i think it did explosive numbers
in china as well so they serve that
audience as well um
so
that's where it kind of falls in its
place in history and the timing of how
movies were in general so i understand
that number yeah
yeah that number for me actually has
more to do with
the marketing that i talked about it
really did feel like i think it was
right around this time is when
like they signed up robert downey jr to
do like the other stuff that he ended up
doing but i remember leading up to it a
lot of people thought that this may be
the last time we see him as iron man do
you all remember that moment when it was
like
oh we don't know if we can tie up these
characters for this long um he was only
signed up to do the avengers movie and
robert downey jr is now robert downey jr
now and i remember when they made the
the
it was shortly after this they made the
sony deal and got um
peter parker in they signed up uh the
five like pratt
um scarlett johansson like the the
original avengers they signed them up to
to continue through the rest of phase
four but i think that was part of it i
think part of it was people thinking
this might be your last hurrah
to see robert downey jr do this
character because i i do think that you
know that that's the way it was kind of
set up didn't turn out that way but
that's the way it was at least set up
yeah and there is a uh it's funny the
the the free-falling scene the skydiving
scene
is so cool and it is so well done and
apparently one of the reasons it was so
well done is because the red bull
skydiving team like the team that does
like all those free-for-alls and like
the highest free-for-all like they're
they're probably in outer space when
they do these dives sometimes they were
enlisted for the free-for-all scene and
so when you put that amount of care into
it and yeah there's a ton of cgi in this
movie but i don't know brian for me i
love when i hear stories like that
behind the scenes where it's like no
they actually really cared about making
this movie
i mean that that we didn't even talk
about it but it is actually one of the
most memorable scenes of the entire
movie yeah right he also is controlling
the suit remotely we find that out so in
the moment we think that oh man he's
gonna do this he's there and then it's
like voila i did this from a completely
different location i love that scene and
that that's a cool nugget he's got the
drone technology and i think that during
act three which is when that free uh
fall scene happens jacqueline we're all
just still reeling from what we just saw
with the mandarin twist and we're trying
to piece everything back together and so
maybe in a way that movie ironically
kind of subterfuged its great scene by
giving us so much to chew on during it
yeah i mean
it's so funny
this this movie
is a lot of layers and i'm not gonna say
that all of them work on top of each
other but each individual one when you
separate them is you can definitely tell
what they were trying to do that's the
other reason why i say that the reason
why it maybe feels jumbled and the
reason why it feels a bit of a mess is
this was a movie that was tried that was
tried to be made in the editing room and
the story that they were making just
didn't gel
yeah it just very much feels like at
some point it just went and i wonder
if it's because
of what it was setting up like maybe it
was originally set up to be like tony's
gonna die and then they're like no he's
not you know
is this the movie that y'all would point
to and say that this is why because
shane black is his own director he's
been very successful before iron man 3.
like he didn't need to do iron man 3. he
wasn't just plucked out of security to
direct this movie so is this a movie in
the mcu that you all would point to and
say well yeah that's because like
is it like an edgar wright maybe doing
ant-man situation where you get into
this movie and then you realize oh i
don't really have all the creative
control i thought i would have
i mean yes that's a great point
specifically talking about how it does
feel like two different pieces and you
know we've seen the reluctance of even
um
correct me if i'm wrong uh is it scott
erickson the
doctor strange director for the first
movie derek sorry scott dirksen um you
know he he did doctor strange one and he
was on board to do doctor strange too
and then kind of during that development
process where he was already committed
to doctor strange too he pulled out
right sam raimi comes in and so
the power of either play nice with us
and have fun and be able to accept that
we're gonna take away some of your
creative liberties um those two actors
specifically edgar wright and scott
derrickson they were and then maybe
maybe they saw it with shane black
kind of showed us behind the scenes
what's happening whether you want to
play ball or not yeah also there's also
a pantheon of directors who didn't i
mean ava was the original director of
black panther let's not forget um she
was the one that marvel went after very
heavily and it's funny when i did the
set visit for black panther nate moore
who's uh been elevated into a higher
level of executive producer but i think
his first movie may have been like civil
war winter soldier
he talked about how when they were
approaching some directors
to like do some of these things after
the edgars and after what happened with
the guy that directed thor the dark
world uh they were having a hard time
because these directors talk they they
it's a very small sort of collegiate
group and they talked about how working
for marvel because they were planning
these movies 20 years in advance
you're not given what you want and i
think they kind of changed their formula
a little bit
for that like they
i think they gave less dictatorial
information and more parameters like you
have to include this you have to include
that you have to include this
play with what you will in between and i
think josh uh wheaton joss wheaton uh
talked about that too when he talked
about uh age of ultron which i have an
article on rotten tomatoes that talks
about how much he set up in that movie
that got paid off later and if you think
about now like how you have to write
your way out of like probably 50 million
different notes you maybe understand why
some director's like nawson i'm gonna go
do my little indie movie check them out
yeah that's why i feel like black
panther is actually the best example of
the mcu allowing a director to serve
their own vision but also tie it into
the larger context of the mcu i thought
ryan coogler would just walk that line
so well because he he's already he's an
established person by then too but he
was able to work within the sandbox but
also express his vision and i think
that's probably why black panther is
arguably the best or one of the most
beloved mcu movies that
we've ever gotten so on that note before
we transition into mailbag just quickly
brian jacqueline your top three mcu
movies if you have my fan i love putting
people on the spot your top three mcu
movies
i've actually thought about this for a
long time so i kind of know my top five
and well you go first and i need to look
at a list yeah once you look up the list
that just like barnstormed the table and
i'm like hey y'all got to order right
now what who's going first i'm serious
okay all right i'll let i'll let
jacqueline do her her look up and be
like okay i guess so i'm gonna
maybe some people agree with me or not
uh i think winter soldier
and civil war have always kind of been
one or two for me but i typically
because i like a little more character
dive and isolation on a character i lean
towards winter soldier as number one for
me i go civil war
is number two
um and then
i'm gonna put man you give me the top
three
because i i cuz typically infinity war
black panther and
then i give credit to iron man being the
first that started are in that top five
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say black
panther number three i'm gonna go with
black panther number three all right i i
have to put an avengers movie in there
somewhere so it's just a matter of if
it's the first avengers movie if it's
end game and i almost count captain
america's civil war as an avengers movie
because that's basically what it is but
i i would probably put the first
avengers at number three and then my two
favorite standalone movies uh at the one
and two spot which would be number one
would be iron man for me and number two
would be black panther and then nice
i'll do three i'll go the original
avengers to be different um jacqueline
did we give you enough time to decide
what you'd like to order for lunch f
y'all man this is hard like
i feel like everybody studied for the
assignment and i'm just i didn't care
like this i'm sitting here like trying
to like copy across the thing okay so
like legitimately and this is not just
me like repping my black girl pride
legitimately black panther was a
cinematic experience for me and i
cannot talk to you uh the moment when
killmonger sits on the throne and that
like
camera rotates is one of my favorite
all-time shots in the marvel cinematic
universe i just it says so much like the
world turned upside down literally love
that so much so amazing black panther's
definitely at the top and
i have love for thor
in a way that people don't understand
because thor
keys into like british
like
um regency television shows which i've
watched more of than comic book
adaptations if it had corsets and a
british accent i've seen it so i really
like thor
um but i would say that of that series
thor ragnarok is my favorite so i have
to pick a thor movie and so i'm gonna
pick ragnarok and then for the third one
honestly
i guess it would be
it would be civil war it would be
captain america civil war um
because the the the kid uh the the the
airplane scene i just i love that
airplane scene so much especially when
he's like where are you from kid and
he's just like you know
queens brooklyn like i just uh i love
that that is like one of my all-time
favorite moments but honorable mention
of the guardians of the galaxy yeah i
mean there's we could do this all uh
yeah i didn't want to say it we could do
this all day yeah there you go i could
do this all day what about shanghai and
like yeah i'll also say like sean chi
makes some strong cases to be in
anybody's top five absolutely absolutely
i think for me shanghai like you know
we're talking about reppin for you know
for our community not being bashful
about it i mean shanghi would probably
be a top five movie for me but if i
remove myself from the fact that i just
saw the first asian superhero i still
put in my personal top ten but not top
five yeah how great was it for you brian
your experience monday night really
quick without giving away anything in
the new movie how how much fun was it
for you to be at that premiere well you
know i mean it quite honestly like
thanks for indulging me it was historic
for the asian american community quite
honestly i i understand the feelings and
you know i cried when i saw black
panther but i understood even more when
i saw uh shang qi
and at least had those relatable
feelings it's important and i i think
more of like the younger generation and
even older generations who have felt
left out that they can finally see
someone on the platform of marvel of mcu
just have someone that looks like them
and i think everyone deserves that and i
think that marvel what's cool about this
is that they at least had the foresight
to do this like we had all the
controversy around some you know like
stop asian hate well they were already
developing this movie so it wasn't like
this comes out two or three years after
stop asian hate in a response to that
movement so i do appreciate that their
thinking is like let's involve these
characters and also quite honestly the
movie was unlike anything we've seen
because it's a martial arts action flick
yeah so the action itself is freaking
badass even from that standpoint alone
so i just really you know enjoyed it but
as a comic book moviegoer let's take out
every you know you know how i felt
personally i still thought it was a
great movie it was awesome
yeah those fight scenes are are just
ridiculous there's a lot of heart
there's a lot of humor in it and
aquafina might be my favorite performer
on the planet right now i i cannot get
enough of her if you if you haven't seen
norah from queens it's you're missing it
she's i'll tell you
yeah i'll tell you right now sorry to
step on you i was surprised by
aquafina's performance because i was a
little quite honestly a little worried
um what she might do in shanghai and
maybe take away from the movie but uh
this movie is not nearly as funny
without her no and she played it i think
right like she played this
very much within the authenticity of
herself and the character you know what
i mean and
i i think this one probably more closely
resembles
literally like nora in her element with
her friends and what she's doing and
less
the character of aquafina and i think
that's refreshing to see it's sort of
the same way i feel when i see tiffany
haddish just do something a little bit
more straight it feels it feels a little
bit more there it doesn't mean that they
can't do the big broad comedy stuff
obviously they can and they do but it
yeah it feels uh
feels a little bit a little bit more
lived in yeah looking forward to all of
our listeners and viewers thoughts on
shanghai and how they feel like it fits
into the marvel cinematic universe and
particularly how it relates to the movie
we just talked about iron man 3 and that
sort of sets us up for our next segment
which is mailbag
you can email us anytime with your
thoughts your questions your concerns
what you want us to talk about rt is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com that's rt is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com this is from
esteemed member of the ketchup crew
jackson borin and he says hello there
lucy and i assume he's probably saying
hi to us too jacqueline big fan of the
show running back to bring up a title i
have been hearing get a lot of
reappraisal on twitter over the past
year since its 25th anniversary in 2020
that's right it's water world i've been
a fan of this movie for years defending
it from those who claim it's just the
mad max ripoff the action and design of
this film is so much better than critics
originally gave it credit for many
choosing to focus on the budget issues
the film faced the set pieces were
understandably difficult to shoot on
water but still paid off and gave the
film a tactile environment that is lost
in today's uncanny valley dennis hopper
was to stand out as the scenery chewing
villain and james newton-howard's score
was phenomenal at 48 percent waterworld
is way too low for the epic ride it
takes viewers on please consider
covering it on rotten tomatoes is wrong
thank you jackson i need to go revisit
waterworld again i like what he said
about the practical sort of effects and
yeah it was it must have been a pain and
that's why it went so over budget to
shoot on actual water but it's nice to
see some practical effects right yeah
also water world made money i always
like want to correct the record actually
i'm down for this one because i have
love in my heart for water world and
kevin costner's guilds
get d up i like that movie as well
uh i feel we're not far from it
the apocalypse is nice so you could look
at it as
instructional as well as entertaining
you'll see that hugh jackman movie
reminiscence you get some underwater
stuff brian do you have love in your
heart for water world um i have love in
my heart for the live-action show at
universal studios oh yeah there you go
okay so that i'll leave it at that but
yeah i got what i got water world love
i just i love that jaclyn is that person
who's just gonna like literally weasel
her way into a conversation about water
world so she can say that the movie did
in fact made money made money like i
just like it's always profitable not
profitable it was a profitable movie it
made money it just cost a ton and it
should have made more but waterworld did
not lose the studio john carter lost the
studio money oh wow now she's throwing
john carter out all right well another
movie that needs to be reevaluated it's
time to wrap up the show thank you by
the way for the email jax we probably
will do water world at some point
because i'm into that lucy let's put
that on the docket uh in the meantime
the movie that definitely did make money
is iron man 3 over a billion dollars
worth and i had a blast talking with
jacqueline and brian about it brian tong
thank you so much for for coming back to
the show thanks for saying hey and it
was great hanging out with you at the
movie earlier this week let's do that
again uh what are some of the things
that you're working on right now i know
everybody can go check out your youtube
channel what else you got going on
yeah some stuff cooking i got a bunch of
shanxi coverage coming up um you know
just kind of the review of the film but
also working on a uh behind the scenes
with some of the visual concept design
team so you know check out youtube.com
brian tom if you want to see what's
coming up with uh all that good stuff
what the movie comes out september 3rd
so uh it'll be ready for then love it
absolutely love it and do you have a
recommendation for us today like
something that is currently streaming or
that we can go check out that you think
the people need to see well
you know you talk about christmas themed
shows
i've gotta i've gotta lean heavy into
ted lasso okay ted lasso has surprised
me i put it off for six months i was
like i don't need to watch this show i
need to watch this show and
there there's an episode that has to do
with christmas that is in
august so
everyone check out ted lasso if you can
if not what's like 5 or 10 bucks just
for a month to just binge through it all
on apple tv plus
that show has lifted us up and i feel
like it's the right type of show for the
right type of time right now so that
that works well with it as well yeah i
love ted lasso and a friend of mine
maui's uh molly the underdog's mom as a
matter of fact ted lasso sent her a
bunch of those like biscuits that they
have which which we call cookies and she
gave them to me and oh my god they're
they're
they're just unbelievable
if we did this in studio jack when i
would have brought enough for the rest
of the class but we don't so i get to
just hoard them all thank you all so
much for listening to us you can email
us like i said anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com wherever you're
listening and enjoying to the podcast
subscribe rate review whatever that app
likes you to do please do it and tell
your friends about it because we talk
about cool movies like iron man 3 and
maybe someday on some distant planet
water world in the meantime for our
great guest brian tong maya's team
co-host jacqueline coley brian perez
behind the scenes producee lucy and her
entire family who may or may not have
been the reason she didn't get to see
shanghai with the rest of us earlier
this week my name is simply mark ellis
thanks for listening to rotten tomatoes
is wrong and we'll catch you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you